you know Chris the things that you and I
have taught for many decades now in that
opener are we kind of just used to them
mmm you know we we live that way so long
we don't think about it and times like
these highlight how wonderful it is to
be debt-free
yeah highlight how wonderful it is to
have an emergency fund how wonderful it
is to be in a position that I don't have
to worry if my investments go down
because I know they're going to come
back up how wonderful it is to have a
paid-for home and not be worrying about
a house payment I mean and I've been
living that way for so long and you have
and we've been teaching it for so long
it almost just feels like if I know that
it's weird statistically in America but
among the among people in this building
and among the the verbage that you and I
use coming out of our mouths on a daily
basis it's just normalized now and it
really is what different I mean where
cash really is king yeah I know Jesus is
king don't let me some religious email
for you oversight people but I know
Jesus is king Jesus the king of my life
shut up okay but the I get that but I
mean cash right now from a financial
perspective if you're sitting on $25,000
cash and you have no house payment and
no payments you're in a completely
different headspace then if you're
sitting on twenty five thousand dollars
in credit card debt thirty thousand
dollars in student loan debt a ten
thousand dollar car payment and no cash
yeah Dave I think you know throughout
this tough spot we're gonna have an
opportunity to get more people to wake
up and tune in and I think hopefully
we'll get some people ready to change
the cash where we can help I hope I hope
so I hope that this serves as that
lesson where you go this is the final
one this is the one this is the where
you say that that phrase never again and
it comes from your heart from the bottom
of your heart and you look at this and
you say I'm growing forward but I'm
never gonna feel this way again and I
hope you people wake up to that and and
have that that spirit about them that
spirit of fight not flight because this
is something we've got to stand up to no
and you know my kids are grown they're
all debt-free
they've all got money saved because they
were raised this way so my grandbabies
are okay mmm-me when we say change your
family tree right now you know what we
did last night we grilled steaks at the
Ramseys and everybody was there all my
grandbabies hug Papa Dave's neck and you
know we really weren't talking about any
of this stuff we were just talking about
what's happening here at the office
we're talking about each other talking
about things that each of them are doing
in their personal lives talk about
what's happening with each grandbaby
we were not and I'm not bragging I'm
just saying it's a weird place in the
middle of all it's like you're standing
in the middle of a hurricane and you're
inside of a brick house and you just
calm mmm and I want that for all of you
that are out there listening hi Chris
and I we want that for you I got that
because I was stupid that's how I got
there because I did dumb things 35 40
years ago and I and then when a storm
hit it wasn't a national storm it sort
of was but it was a not about it not
about this but it was a storm hit this
and El crisis hit and changed the
bankers and the way they were thinking
and they called my notes and we lost
everything we owned and I found I had
that moment and it was so painful I was
so scared I was so terrified because I
had Doug's such a deep hole it was so
painful that it was the lesson was so
thorough mmm and I mean I want this for
you guys for some of you they're hurting
right now we're gonna help you get
through it we're gonna walk you through
it we're Financial Peace University is
14-day free trial right now for you jump
out and take the whole class right now
free and you can't we've never done that
before by the way but a bunch of you got
14 days at home just go to Dave Ramsey
comm slash hope there's a bunch of stuff
there to help you but what we want is we
want you this to be the time and you can
I can look back to September 23rd 1988
is the day I file bankruptcy
and you can look back to April the first
20 2014 au be 20 60 I'll be dead and
some of you'll be looking back going
that's the day that my family tree
changed mmm that's the day I finally got
my wake-up call and I picked the phone
up that's the day I got scared enough
that I said never again yesterday I got
angry enough that I said never again I'm
not gonna be subject to an economy that
can be completely collapsed by hysteria
yeah
I'm not gonna be subject to a series of
people losing their minds over things
I'm not gonna be subject to a virus that
invades our house to the extent that I
can obviously can't control the medical
aspects of it I don't mean that but I'm
not gonna set myself I'm gonna control
the controllables so that when the storm
comes I'm like the little pig in the
brick house and I'm the one in the straw
house because it's not a matter of win
if the store comes Tom comes it's just a
matter win that's exactly right and
that's not being pessimistic all why
that's right
I I read somewhere and I started
tweeting out years ago that information
that that you that you take in just
becomes information but information that
you apply in your life gives you an
opportunity to have wisdom and a lot of
us right now are gaining some wisdom and
looking at this situation sadly it often
comes from pain oh it has not the wisdom
that I have a lot of it was when I was
stupid me too and I got experience and
right after experience that somebody
said your wisdom wise where'd you get
where'd you get your wisdom I got it
from experience where'd you get
experience from being stupid well I
noticed you went immediately to the date
of your bankruptcy and that interest
that day I remember when we thought oh I
know you do member hacelle I remember
how am I you know my throat was tight my
voice was up three octaves because of
the stress my stomach was up in my eye I
mean you know tears are welling up in
your eyes and stomachs up in your throat
and I'm driving away like I'm driving
away from a funeral
from that lawyer's office you know
because it was a
part of me died that day because I'm a
guy keeps your word and I couldn't keep
my word because I was stupid I'm
painting myself in the corner I got
paint on my feet it was my fault
now people did stuff to us the outside
economy impacted us but we did not
control the controllables because we
thought that we could violate these
principles and still come out on top and
you can't you can't beat the law of
gravity it'll kick your butt that does
Dave for the people that are out there
right now potential looming job loss
income cut in half what are the
controllables now you know if you got
that kind of a thing you got to look at
creating income right number one number
two you you stop paying extra on
anything I stopped any baby steps if
you're looking at a looming job loss
right and I pile up cash if you got
steady jobs keep working your steps
right right but if you if you're there
if your restaurant worker and you're
laid off and you're gonna go over here
and work for Amazon for a while or
Target until you know whoever's hiring
right there'll of people hiring until
you get back on your feet
then you stop everything right now you
take care of the four walls food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
everything else is on hold right here it
is